nuevo giro en la política internacional
de joe biden el gobierno de eeuu anunció
que reanudará la ayuda económica y
humanitaria para la población palestina
una ayuda que su predecesor donald trump
había suspendido
planeamos reiniciar la asistencia
económica para el desarrollo y la
seguridad humanitaria de eeuu al pueblo
palestino y la asistencia a los
palestinos cumple con importantes
intereses y valores de eeuu para dar
apoyo a los que lo necesitan fomentar el
desarrollo económico y apoyar el
entendimiento entre israelíes y
palestinos la ayuda total asciende a 235
millones de dólares más 15 millones que
el gobierno estadounidense ya había
asignado para ayudar a la respuesta
contra la pandemia en los territorios
palestinos 150 millones se destinarán a
la agencia de las naciones unidas para
los refugiados palestinos 75 millones
serán para asistencia a gaza y
cisjordania y 10 millones se invertirán
en programas de consolidación de paz
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
palestinos celebró la noticia y aseguró
que el apoyo estadounidense permitirá
mantener programas de abastecimiento
alimentario salud y educación entre
otros
la situación ha sido absolutamente
terrible y en un sentimiento de abandono
de la comunidad internacional
creo que la participación de eeuu dará
un rayo de esperanza
en cambio israel se mostró decepcionado
por el anuncio y aseguró que las ayudas
a la agencia de la onu podrían incitar
al conflicto